oh yeah never never I did millionair
coming from Oklahoma I think I'd end up
in a a jungle like this down here in
skido you know what I mean or anywhere
close to it how how long you been down
here uh I came in March the 18th would
have been my touchdown date uh in
California I came to uh I came and got
clean in rehab and then got out of rehab
and relapsed again oh so you came out
here for a rehab came out here for a
rehab yeah somebody sold me somebody
sold me a dream out in Malibu so
um yeah they uh they did it pretty good
it was a nice little place but I ended
up going back over there once and then
um met met a girl and um you know how it
goes with a girl you kind of intend to
follow where she flocks so um we ended
up leaving rehab and coming down closer
to skido and uh that ended very abruptly
after I moved in with her and I ended up
out on the street so what is your drug
huh what is your what is your drug uh
Fenton meth I mean yeah and uh I came to
get clean because my little brother he
killed himself back in February of uh 20
2020 it's about to be 2024 so 2023 he he
took his life yeah for what reason I
don't even can't even explain it it's
very super abrupt um how did you do it
he shot he shot fent all
intravenously took one big hot shot and
uh just kind of checked out think it was
a suicide attempt uh from he was also my
best friend too um I don't think anybody
could ever been closer we had our own
place together we did everything
together um from everything that I knew
about him in the way that we both used
drugs together absolutely you know um he
was very cautious about things like it
wasn't just a a random OD I don't no way
like he had the tolerance built up and
everything to we you know you know um he
had to have done too much to be able to
uh not wake up like that so and we were
both at the end of our runs and I I
don't know we we kind of I told I
there's a lot of regret right there I I
told told him that we couldn't be around
each other anymore and we were starting
to do some bad things to each other and
like uh he was stealing from me so I
start stealing from him and um lo and
behold I guess he just didn't want to be
here anymore after that you know so
um that's that's been a lot to process
you know I'd say I'm sorry about that
but yeah life life goes on you know and
uh still have to keep my feet moving you
know as long as as long as I'm breathing
I have to do something about it you know
um and while you've been down here
living on the streets you you have a
tent or you just on the street I'm on
the street on the street I don't even
have a tent right now uh I don't I don't
I don't really trust it enough to uh to
put put a tent down anywhere because you
don't never know when you're when your
stuff's going to get moved or broken
into you're going to lose it again so
it's got to be hard when it's cold and
raining yeah it's been pretty cold man
yeah uh luckily Oklahoma is endur I've
been able to endure the weather there
but the California is a different type
of temperature too and the whole it's a
different world out here man it really
is it's it's crazy you know it's total
different world different scene
different Hood different everything you
know how are you making money uh uh
right now I can be completely honest
about everything so I boost for the most
part that's the most common thing that
people yeah yeah yeah I boost um I try
to not most but like if we're being
honest it's an everyday thing you know
um you you got to be able to eat and
feed yourself so how how do you how do
you boost how do you steal from a so how
do I boost how do I steal from like a
department store like a Target or
something like that uh so if first I
would just walk in and grab the stuff
off the shelves and um walk straight out
and
uh that would be it so and you've been
caught huh have you been caught still
haven't been I mean I've been caught by
employees and everything like that but
not by the police yet never been taken
in on boosting charge or anything like
that um still do it every day uh so
knock on wood let's hope that the the
ball keeps rolling like that that
nothing help nothing uh unravels but do
you ever see yourself being somebody
who's like surviving by stealing from no
man from where I'm from we don't do that
type of stuff you know we uh I grew up
in Oklahoma I'm born and raised from
Oklahoma City Oklahoma and we don't
we're not we we don't look down even in
the kind of the drug world we kind of
look down upon thate what was your
family like growing up my family uh it
was it was divided so when my parents
have been divorced since I was about 6
weeks old
um my dad he uh had so custody over me
for the most part I lived with my mom
from about 12 to 15 and then uh finished
up with my dad and then moved back down
with my mom lived with her from about 18
to 22 and off and on through my 20s um
but other than that family life
was sporadic let's just say that I don't
I can't tell you I've never eaten a full
meal with my family or anything like
that my mom and dad have never sat down
with me at a dinner table there or
anything so um it's always been divided
very divided uh which is I don't know
it's kind of hard to think about not not
being able to have that like every you
see everybody else they've always eaten
dinner with their their mom and dad
Christmas like with your family
Christmas Christmas is Christmas is a
big deal on on my on my mom's side um on
my dad's side not so much they there my
grandpa was a jice witness so he didn't
really ever uh he didn't really ever uh
practice holidays or anything like that
um mom's side we're big on Christmas we
always do it big we make sure we get we
got do the full Italian food special and
make sure we get all get stuffed and so
how how did you spend Christmas this
year a couple days ago uh let's see I
was sick cold and in the rain so uh by
myself too so it was uh it was
definitely not the not the best
Christmas but um I'm still glad that I'm
breathing you know what I mean have
you
uh I not purposely no
um I don't I don't think so no I don't
think I have can't can't recall an event
where I actually have uh I I don't
really do drugs as much anymore to get
get higher get [__] up is like I've
got a lot of pain like physical pain
I've been over was over 300 lb most of
my life and really yeah so
um I was kind of kind of spoiled and
always got to have the full load of the
kitchen and everything like that and
didn't really have any much discipline
when it came to food or diet or anything
like that and so I was in a size 42 by
the time I was in fourth grade wow yeah
so
um which it crazy to me but um when
you're when you're when I guess when
you're that size and everything like
that things things changed for you so um
you finished school yeah I finished
school I I uh actually graduated full on
on time um I don't know how I did that I
pulled that out of my ass I ended up
gaining like 10 credits I I was
considered a freshman in my senior year
of high school and kind of just made it
happen you know I've always been somehow
some way I've been able to survive
anything or skate by or get get through
any kind of thing that I need to get
through just by the hair of my teeth you
graduated high school huh you graduated
high school I did yeah yeah I actually
did uh um when did drug use start for
you my drug you started when I was about
12 or 11 years old uh started with a
joint um me and my step brother we
smoked a joint out back before
Thanksgiving and then uh
um that just kind of accelerated from uh
ended up finding some pills and then
found found some pills found that the
name of him looked around for him at
school if somebody else had some and it
turned out to be Aderall I was a big
Aderall head in high school and
everything like that so that didn't
realize that ader all was actually full
on speed and everything like that but um
what for whatever it did for me uh it
kind of filled that void that I've been
looking for like I always felt like I
was missing a connection with something
you know what I mean like I felt always
felt a little bit dis always
disconnected or set apart from everybody
else just from the the [__] that I went
through when I was so young um when I
was when I was three I was in Oklahoma
City Bombing I survived the muray
building bombing yeah where were you in
the bombing Heaven I was in the daycare
so I don't know if you know where the
YMCA daycare was at um so they had the
basically you had the Murray building
right here and then the this is where
the truck was parked YMCA and then the
the Daily Oklahoma which was the
newspaper um and way the blast wasan was
actually directed at the building but
the the the daycare YMCA daycare was
actually just is close and so uh I was 3
years old I'll never forget it it was
it's a crazy day man it was a really
crazy day what happened to the building
you were in huh what happened to the
building not every [__] window that
was in there I'll tell you that uh I
I'll never forget looking up actually
about ceilings like that about that tall
looking up and there's furniture and
[__] all like everywhere and uh people
running in grabbing people and wrapping
us all up in towels and everything and
the ceiling's falling in on us and I'm
just kind of wondering like why the [__]
is this happening you know like Dazed me
that you 3 years old yeah I was 3 years
old you remember it yeah everything
every single single thing about it I
guess you remember something like that
yeah yeah my dad dropped me off about
7:00 A.M that morning and um from there
I think I ate my sausage biscuit that he
gave me and played around with the kids
and then they sat us down to read us a
story to take a nap and uh you know I
remember looking outside to the left and
paying attention in the store and then
coming to and just telling you what I
told you there there's people running
rushing in and it's like a damn war
scene in there and um ceiling was
falling in I couldn't understand why the
ceiling was falling in like and I was
like wow what the hell of course I
didn't consciously say what wow what the
hell or anything like that but um I
remember being outside my mom was
actually working about two blocks away
and I'll never forget it because still
this day it makes me like kind of jump
sometimes when she screams my name just
Bradley Bradley all all the way through
I I I heard her two blocks away you know
what I mean like she she was she was
there and she found me and she grabbed
me and uh the towels I was wrapped in
were covered in blood from head to toe I
had multiple multiple lacerations
through my head they glass huh yeah it
was literally stuck in my skull they had
to pull out with the with pliers when I
got to the hospital but she was able to
get me into the hospital
um and in
into into the uh into the emergency room
pretty much before anybody got there
because it was all all ambulatory at
that point you know there was so many
people coming in and they were being
shipped to every different which
hospital and uh so she ran I'll never
forget she had me I could have been 30
40 pounds in her hand she ran in high
heels all the way to the car you know
what I mean and uh yeah she got me there
and they put me on a stretcher and on
never they had to literally restrain me
um sit on top of me and everything I
don't know why they didn't put me under
I think I was a little too young for
anesthesia or something like that but
um
they frying that glass out of my head
but uh I had multiple MRIs for me gave
me a TBI is like brain brain injury uh
traumatic brain injury to my left
temporal lobe which has to deal with
processing emotions impulses and uh
impulse impulse Pro anything that has to
do with um situations and scenes I kind
of I have to navigate through a little
bit differently or slower sometimes uh
but then at first also I had to learn
how to use a fork and all kinds of stuff
again but uh like I said I always kind
of felt separated like just distant from
everybody because I don't know that was
so such a heavy moment in my life that
like nothing ever seemed as exciting or
intriguing you know what I mean so
um are you are you an adrenaline junkie
yeah my my therapists have told me that
I am a dopamine junkie anything I can do
to get a dopamine release I will um
so that goes back to what we were
talking about just a second ago is that
once I found that first drug the one
thing that made my heart flutter in the
right way I uh I got a hold of it you
know what I mean
so that was crystal meth uh it was
actually ater all at the time I didn't I
didn't search out the crystal meth until
I was probably 18 or 19 but um in that
whole meantime I was doing other
[__] you know Petty crimes and stuff
like that during High School to uh for
no reason like I grew up good I had
everything I was taken care of I just I
wanted something to do everything else
seems so boring you know what I mean so
um and I didn't it's not like I didn't
make bad grades or anything like that
uh so yeah I I graduated high school on
time from there should have gone to
college but I didn't
um and are drugs why you didn't I think
it was more fact of the reason that
I proba drugs probably but I just like I
always wanted to go to to college like I
wanted to go at one point I wanted to go
to military school and [__] and I don't
know I always felt I was just lazy you
know there lazy part of me it was very
lazy I didn't have much discipline when
I was a kid you know and uh I feel like
a lot of that has uh set me short in the
long run uh I think I could accomplish a
little bit more if I would just pushed
myself a little bit harder how old are
you now 31 31 yeah 31 and and the fact
that you're 31 living on skidrow
homeless yeah addicted to drugs does
that make you reconsider some of your
decisions every single one of them yeah
every single one what's your biggest
regret
biggest
regret uh follow my own lead and not
listening to people that knew better um
before me or or even
just I guess my biggest regret is trying
to run the show constantly yeah it's so
hard for me to trust trust not letting
go of the own process you know I guess
it says in AA that we we have to let go
of the Reigns and let let's somebody
else do our bidding or our will be be
done by somebody else but um it's it's
always just been so hard for me to not
have
[Music]
to just make some bad decisions you know
what I mean and like I regret them now
because I'm getting tired you know what
I mean I'm getting tired and I'm ready
I'm ready for a peaceful life and I want
uh I want some of my life back when I
was about 20 25 I got clean for about 5
years and experienced some some deep joy
in that how were those years they're
amazing they they're amazing I had so
what what what is keeping you from
trying to get back
there
um honestly right now
uh
just facing some of the [__] that I've
had to do lately you know what I mean
like look at myself and the issues that
I've created and all the turmoil that
I've caused with me and my family and
how to navigate through all that and um
there's a lot of two- faced [__] that
I've done and and things that I've said
and that I haven't been able to follow
through on and or things that I've
wanted to do that I haven't been able to
do and um I think that I'm just very
disappointed in myself and uh I'm very
[__] ashamed of myself and the way
I've acted over last few years which
because I know I've made a lot of
selfish selfish selfish selfish mov and
uh I know I could have done way better
and I think right now I just got my foot
on my damn neck and I don't know how to
take it off at this point are you are
you self-destructive very yeah yeah very
I don't know and I can't say that I
enjoy it but at the same way in the same
time like I keep doing it you know what
I mean so it's like I I feel stuck you
know what I mean I feel stuck and I feel
uh alone you know it's hard for me to uh
I can't even get a hold of my family
anymore you know what I mean I can I
don't know I don't even know how to get
a hold of my mama I don't even know her
number you know my the only family I
know they won't even give me her number
to call her on Christmas you know what I
mean like and I uh I guess it's the
support too you know um I've always felt
like if I don't have anybody backing me
then like what's the point you know
nobody believes in me then why should I
believe in myself you know what I mean
and so like my value and my worth to
become where I'm at today you know the
way I've see and value myself is where
I've kind of stuck myself if that makes
sense yeah it does so what's your
biggest fear
now dying alone out
here I don't want that to happen I do
not want that to happen it scares me
because I can see it happening and
knowing what happened to your brother
yeah I don't think I don't think I'd be
privy to take my own life um no but but
you're you're smoking fentanyl yeah or
you're injecting fentanyl no I don't
inject it you smoke it yeah but smoking
fentanyl you could possibly yeah yeah
yeah do that um yeah and like I said the
only reason I I really do drugs now is
because like I I've been shot three
times and some people like I've had
major extensive surgeries and [__] and
you've been shot where uh so I was shot
in the uh stomach 38 hollow point
somebody tried to kill me this was where
this was August the 21st of 2021 in
Oklahoma yeah in Oklahoma um I was on
drugs and gang banging down there and uh
so
basically uh somebody came up and they I
grabbed the gun from them when they
tried to pull the trigger and squeeze to
my head and the gun went off right here
and went Bam Bam one went out and
through and and then the other one split
my femur in half and I uh and I put
ended up going into uh like cardiac
through so much pain and uh Lo losing a
lot of blood and
basically
um uh I have a titanium femur now I woke
up on a ventilator six days later with a
stint in my heart and all kinds of stuff
and so uh I suffer from a lot of chronic
pain nowadays too and uh I think that
plays in my used a lot too now is that
that was a very scary moment in my life
after some more traumatic [__] happened
that I haven't been able to get into yet
um I at that sober period I coming off
that serber period I relaps pretty hard
Ed up uh leaving my my my ex and leaving
a whole house and entire life behind
just for drugs you know what I mean and
I pissed away a giant bank account and
did all this stuff and the way that that
ended was me near near nearly dying so
um I think it scared the [__] out of me
to see how how uh how close I did push
it on that one and then so once I got
healed up from that um I went back and
started doing the same thing and I think
it's just crazy how I just can't see why
I keep going back to what I don't know
what I'm looking for you know what I
mean feel like there's something I'm
looking for that I can't find this
answer to this this this feeling that am
I am I just what am I chasing here and
uh because I got to be done eventually
or I'm not going to have time for to
live a life you know what I mean so do
you have kids not yet always wanted to
be a dad always wanted to be a dad have
you been in love before yeah yeah sure
have what happened there uh well one of
them they uh
they didn't love me back as much as they
thought thought they did I guess and
then that happens the other one they
didn't
uh I don't know she was very way younger
and I don't think she I think I just uh
kind
of pushed her away too much pushed her
away too hard I was very got very mean
you know but yeah I I I've been love it
was Love's a great thing love will
inspire you love will do amazing things
you know what I mean can also be a very
very bad bad deal too you know it
doesn't work out huh when it doesn't
work out yeah when it doesn't work out I
think it's it can be heartbreaking man
it can really be heartbreaking you know
and have oh man yeah it can be very
heartbreaking but they
uh they they were some good girls and
I'm truly grateful for to have to have
had them in my life you know what I mean
uh I'm still in touch with one of them
today
she checks on me every once in a while
get on Facebook and I'll see that she's
messaged me and messag her back and
she'll sit there and talk to me for a
minute make sure that I'm okay and all
that so I know that that there's got to
be something there that you know keeps
keeps some keeps some type of Hope going
in me um but yeah man this Play Skid
Rose being a being a southern boy from
Oklahoma coming over here into the big
city man I I didn't know know what I was
getting into you know what I mean doggy
dog out here it is Dog Eat Dog big time
and you know it it is is something that
it's wolf eat wolf that's what it is yes
it is Alpha you Alpha you know um you
definitely you definitely got to be on
your p's and q's you better you better
know what respect is and you better know
how to make your own money and take care
of yourself it it'll toughen up a white
boy ain't nobody going to do [__] for
you around here that's for sure that's
for damn sure yeah but uh I don't know
hopefully one day make it out and be
able to give back to what everybody's
getting giving me and do something good
for this place around here is my biggest
hope you know what I mean Bradley what
would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life in my
life
uh love no matter what it's a great one
love no matter
what can't I mean why not yeah if you
got it give it you know what I mean yeah
it's beautiful yeah beautiful lesson
love no matter what you got to you you
know what I mean it's just this is one
of those things where if you don't if
you don't
see I would rather I would rather be
able to give somebody my last and know
that they truly truly needed it and were
grateful for it than to give somebody my
last that didn't give a damn about it
and to still do it out of love you know
what I mean because that way one way or
another I knew that I was still doing
the right thing by me at least I don't
know about by then but
um and love is not giving love is an
action you know love Love's a big big
deal is love is an action it's it's not
just a a word you know there's a lot
that goes behind love that uh people I
think forget about you know you can't
just tell somebody you love them and not
not let them see it you know what I mean
it goes within the way you treat them
the way you act towards them the way you
talk about them the way you feel about
them the way you look at them the way
your your body language is around it's
all those things you know and there's
different levels and there's different
ways and I don't know love's a big deal
to me man it is uh I've always
uh I don't know I've always chosen love
over everything if my if if my mom was
to pull up right now and say get in the
car let's go you know what I mean or my
ex was pulling and say get in the car
let's go [__] this [__] it's either me
or them I would get in the car
immediately you know what I mean just
because that's where my heart is my
heart's not right here my heart's with
with all those other people so I feel
like me being down here I'm just kind of
in a Purgatory you know and I hope I
hope one of them comes and gets me you
know what I mean but we we both know
that's not going to happen well maybe
after this video they might [__] you
never know may maybe we could maybe we
could send him a video you know see what
see what happens but uh yeah maybe
they'll finally see how skinny I am you
know been over 300 pounds my entire life
so uh yeah maybe they'll come bring me
something to eat how about that all
right Bradley thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you sir I
appreciate it I wish you lots of luck
yeah thanks
sir